Interplanetary Transmissions: Stardust is
a new book of proceedings from the Santa Fe
Institute's second interplanetary Festival.
Woven throughout this volume are original
writings from some of the visionary scientists
and futurists who spoke at the event and also
10 original works of art.
These pieces consists of two or three meaningful
photographs woven together at the beginning
of each chapter.
We thought about the possibility of weaving
photographs together when we realized that
the human art of textile was a thread that
ran through all of the conversations of the
festivals panels.
So shortly after InterPlanetary wrapped up,
the Santa Fe Institute Press team, the InterPlanetary
team, and SFI's president David Krakauer convened
to figure out how we wanted to visually tether
all of these panels together while still maintaining
that energy.
We started talking about what our favorite
elements of the festival were.
And for a while, we were wrapped up in conversing
about Nicholas de Monchaux's lecture, which
was really about the book that he wrote called
Fashioning Apollo.
Fashioning Apollo was about the history of
the making of the Apollo 11 moon suit.
The suit in and of itself actually is a really
lovely example of complexity.
It's 13 distinct layers.
Each layer is made out of a very specific
material that serves a very specific function,
but when all of those layers are arranged
in a certain order and stitched together that
new composite fabric serves one very crucial
function, which is keeping a human being alive
on the surface of the moon.
And the most interesting thing about that
history is that those suits, these technological
innovations in wardrobe, these great new garments
were engineered actually by the seamstresses
at Playtex.
So the same hands that were making our bras
and our girdles and our pantyhose were the
hands that were responsible for this spectacular
suit.
And that little morsel, that feminine bit
of the history of the Apollo 11 mission was
something that I didn't know about prior to
this interplanetary festival or prior to reading
that book and talking to Nick about it.
So this was really yummy and we wanted to
keep it present.
And when approached this project by virtue
of that conversation, David reminded us all
of the Fairchild semiconductor manufacturing
plant, which was right here in New Mexico
in Shiprock, which is also Navajo nation.
And that plant was predominantly employed
by grossly underpaid Navajo women, the thought
being at the time that because they have a
centuries long culture of weaving and textile
artisanry, they could apply their nimble dexterity
to the manufacturing of semiconductor chips
that would eventually be deployed in a variety
of new technologies.
And from there, we started thinking about
computation in general and how actually the
first computer, the computer from which all
of the computers we use today derived, was
really a loom.
It was a machine that was made for the production
of textiles and the punch cards that allowed
for these very intricate designs to be incorporated
into the fabric were stolen and re-appropriated
and used in the very first versions of the
computers that got us to the Moon.
And so we realized that there was this rich
foundation of textile, of craftsmanship, of
weaving and of handiwork that would essentially
be relegated to women's work.
And that the women who produced these works
were responsible for the foundation upon which
all of our technological achievements depend.
And that was a really lovely thing that we
realized often goes unacknowledged and we
wanted to shed light upon it.
So we started thinking about how to visually
keep that alive in the art for this book.
From there, we all broke up and started brainstorming
about how to achieve this visualization.
And we went a million different directions.
At first, we thought we might include images
of old punch cards from Jacquard looms.
And then we thought we could even encode some
and share secret messages throughout the book
with our readers.
We thought about the fact that humans aren't
the only things on this earth that weave,
and it would be somewhat hubristic and anti-InterPlanetary.
If we only included images of works created
by humans.
So we thought about spiders and their webs,
and perhaps including imagery that relates
to both of those things, the weaver and the
woven item, in this book.
But then we thought that this would be a fun
opportunity to collaborate with some contemporary
fiber artists.
We could highlight their work.
And we could also showcase exactly how the
medium of fiber art has evolved.
We thought about working with a local Navajo
weaver named Melissa Cody.
And then we thought about working with a fabulous
photographer named Kyle Myers who's using
textile and photography in a really clever
way together.
And then we just started thinking about photography
in general, how again, this year was a celebration
of how human beings walked on the moon 50
years ago.
And now at InterPlanetary, we're all staring
up at the moon 50 years later, wondering what's
to come.
And we have a rich library of images from
then to now that are very inspiring in that
way.
So when we first experimented with weaving
photographs together, we learned that really
colorful images suffer from this process,
that highly detailed images suffer from this
process.
So we started thinking about contrast and
void and composition, and we decided to take
some visual components that were present in
each of the festival's panels and weave those
together with the hope that the juxtaposition,
the emergent image would be this emblematic
image of the content that was discussed in
the panel writ large.
We must've done 50 of these pieces before
we settled on the 10 or so that made it into
the book, but it was a really wonderful process.
If our mission was to shed light on this side
of artistry and these invisible women, these
artisans who are behind the technological
scenes, who paved the way for what we've accomplished,
it felt like the weaving itself was a, was
a practice in honoring that medium.
I should also take the opportunity to say
that everyone on the InterPlanetary team and
everyone on the Press team are women.
So while we never explicitly addressed this,
I don't think it was lost on any of us.
When we were sharing a space, talking about
the content of these panels and producing
these pieces in this particular medium for
this book.
So that was a really lovely embodiment of
the type of respect we hope our readers have
for everything we were attempting to draw
attention to.
And I'm really proud of the work that we did.
I think these pieces are gorgeous.
I'm so excited to include them in this volume.
And I hope that you enjoy them too.